play video games and so the worst was
like I didn't have a TV in the box so I
wanted to play video games and if they
were like chilling on the couch you be
like feel like a little kid you're like
are you guys done it's my turn dude the
worst a girl would come in and go like
are you playing Spider-Man and you're
like
yes yeah dude when she when this [__]
is roasting you you're like you're
getting robbed by my idiot friend and
you have that in your back pocket you're
like my friend who's pretty fat and is a
loser is about to ghost you [__] I know
this you don't even look up he go do you
think he's going to text you
back you got a better chance to get a
text back than I do a beaten doc off
over
here I've heard being like are you
playing video games you go [__] I'm 14
and three with the
ners it's the it's Wild Card Weekend
[__] yeah what did you do just get
[__] and now you're going to go of
eggs that are 20 bucks